for the first time ever Xbox one is
coming to China with a full games and
entertainment system here at Microsoft
we have been on a mission to build the
very best gaming entertainment
experiences for gamers everywhere and in
China there are over half a billion
gamers so the opportunity to create
global and local created content to
delight millions and millions of gaming
fans everywhere is something that we're
really passionate about wishing my
options are we run so we'll go for that
we're onto the term dollar sitting son
Julian King she's attacking village
Tempe Xbox one OMG so the cha-ching told
her I [ __ ] so I will ensure hire a
lawyer I seen in Chile was chanting to
work a warm intelligent or able to see
it she shouldn't oh we're at sea well gr
that's really one of the great things
about today's were making a bit of
history jørgen hace más o ok tonga
guandong freedom my god some greater to
see you happy boys are on our teacher yo
yo hit hi sweetie little 20 tons of mayo
panther so no matter how poor you saw
some light mayo teeth on my no
we take on you guys to what hits let's
see that you're not chillin ago my Lots
on Twitter yoshito not is your idea teen
Silvernail event or trigger you devour
the whole time you're naked walk ye with
unity not remember to motor hum even
could be kind of hard all you know for
you can go ad open an able to identify
water rounded on vanguard kubota mostly
no bar-b-que to know from the name to
xbox one is going to offer an amazing
array of experiences for gamers in China
everything from games to entertainment
experiences fitness and education
opportunities well 17 took the time to
jump over to the tree that a single what
my yachts you were going we're and she
does it to the time she talkin to when I
wish you pee on them I lie about expose
so wanna tell me when you chunghae